the name of the next chapter in the Star  Wars saga was finally announced Star  Wars Episode 8 will be called the last  Jedi now there's a lot of speculation  about what that title means but just  this morning the first footage from the  new Star Wars film was leaked online I'm  sorry it's a spoiler but I think it  helps explain the title just a little  bit warning again spoiler alert it's  just boom boom boom I'm going to town so  I look up from this thing and I say to  her you never said you were part wookie  right now you do understand a vasectomy  is not reversible you will never be able  to have children  hey hey hey as long as I don't end up  some Twilight's baby daddy I say snip  snip guess I'm gonna be the last Jedi  doc hello is this procedures  [Applause]  you  you